welcome to this video I'm playing whitey
against the Doofenshmirtz yeah this is a
German German flag optus name and doin
shoe yet see I don't mean stupid and
schmidts is not really a word can beam
can be anything is Charlie pretty high
rated the sky so let's see what he's
doing against my sammich yeah one of
those d65 setups that are quite
remarkably popular somehow transposing
now okay I'll take this chance to pin
the pin the night you know f4 will be
dangerous yeah so he needs to do that
okay now i have obviously castled so it
will not be so easy to to to get this
attack going sometimes you can play a
four anyway obviously a very young
committal decision
but I'm going to do it after the capture
I play Bishop age 44 this pin sorry I'm
having a little snack IAM takes bishop
h4 it's really a big pin okay he's
avoiding that so night a try if now i
guess so i could have gone to d5 maybe
this was better right right due to the
edge of the board ok but it will be
dangerous in any case
okay so e5 or just take on the form I'm
just going to take him this is easy i'm
attending a hive and if he takes again
e5 with the idea to capture on d6 and
taking Bishop b5 is winning right away
cakes but just yeah isn't this instance
it's okay loop takes I just take
everything i'll play play look everyone
Queen g6 is a very a very strong threat
or many good moves problem
something like h4 is also strong takes
rook everyone does queen is six and this
is not winning not directly at least but
each form is probably also not directly
winning it's very close but on the other
hand if we look at this here Queenie 6i
first thinking Bishop you want to see
three maybe but there is Queen III check
unfortunately the ship f2 that's not
it's not the size of its close but not
decisive I could take g6 though maybe
maybe take d 6
yeah this looks good threatening also
Bishop b5 it's not just the pawn it gets
in new threats okay so I cannot check
bishop we should be five now but
probably there should there should be
something Queen f3 may be back here or
just I just need to get the bishop on
the long diagonal also would also win
this should be four maybe but it's a bit
artificial let's Bishop g5 coming
amazing I don't see a win time morning
yet can maybe even take her
amazing them there's no made it looks
like there should be something but I
don't see it 25 seconds now can I keep
doing Adam again and again
yeah we still probably find ways to keep
the game going and not lose instantly
that's not enough I mean that's really
not enough he didn't he didn't get mated
I probably was some some some way to to
kill him but I didn't see it the
pressure to d5 check yeah of course
totally losing yet it's not increment
blitz now the b6 spawn is also very weak
well I managed that lack resides Wow
yeah I keep doing this to me I don't
know why its kind of ultimately crazy
crazy on the time management yeah for a
force of course very very hard move but
i think it was good and it's very strong
young comes directly winning according
to the computer okay i had made a
mistake though probably here i can also
recapture this is stronger CD forward
probably if i don't see that 95 is also
better just just centralizing this also
not this also get screen h5 in in some
in some lines yeah something like this
the very good attack computer wants to
go here with an even bigger attack this
is the idea wow ok now thats this I
wouldn't have seen pretty sure ok I went
here and this is also yeah this is in
fact the best according to the comp II 5
also the best yeah and it gives plus 7
which is not really a surprise but I
didn't find the wind Queen g4 is the one
this is also winning but less convincing
with this line Bishop t6 yeah this is
what I had seen when I took on f6 but
it's still somehow going on krina 3 is
the best one ok at least I managed to
find quite good moves with no time
the clock and here Bishop be one as the
winner this is not winning of course it
should be one is the winner it is still
of course he's still not threatening to
take with both pieces this is checkmate
yeah and this this is of course check so
this i had seen eight you cannot take
with both piece so i can first secure
that and then get through the attack
with quincy three very strong very
strong something like this check Jack
yeah just take it or here cannot it
cannot go anywhere and why this breaking
through okay at this time time craziness
and she a bishop should see eight is
probably not best Jam Queenie seven but
okay very difficult very difficult stuff
and now I get the bishop to d5 and the
the giant game here is check it's
relatively easy when now because of the
dominant bishop on d5 covered by the sea
porn I'm always able to quickly attack
b6 which he probably cannot horde this
was directly going into into this this
end game yeah okay this this is this is
directly losing but he had only a bad
end game snow i take b6 with the rook
next if he moves the rook somewhere so
we have this winning honking an opponent
game now wow crazy crazy stuff but it
turned it again shows that Chandler in
the Z Michelle you should avoid this pin
it's it's simply very dangerous he set
up this this wall but still you could
play a form and only now after a couple
of seconds the computer recognizes how
strong the movies
now that's fairly typical though this F
for most it's nothing I just invented it
it can happen if black is setting our
buttocks setting it up in exactly this
way okay thanks for watching